hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to other
edition of ask Evan in today's video I'm
going to answer questions from one of my
readers Gemma who wrote in asking one of
the biggest business pitfalls that you
can make as an entrepreneur there's a
lot that you can make so I'm going to
cut a narrow it down to three that
hopefully can help you get your business
started the first one is just chasing
the money and not doing something that
you're really passionate about and this
is a pitfall that a lot of entrepreneurs
fall into they get seduced by idea of
making a lot of money think it's going
to be really easy to start whatever
business it is and it's not it's tough
entrepreneurship is tough it's not an
easy game you're going to work harder
than you've ever worked in your life
you're gonna you know sometimes wish it
you just had a full time job instead of
doing your own company but it is really
rewarding at the end when you can get
past that survival point and are able to
build a company that you can be proud of
but those companies the ones who make it
aren't the ones we just chasing the
money they do it because they really
love doing what they're doing they feel
like they can really help people they
feel like they're having an impact and
they're making money at the same time
I'm not asking to be a prophet sorry
nonprofit and just give all your money
away it's still with you to make money
but the main purpose is to add value to
help people and to do something that
you're really passionate out so that's
where I would start start around your
interests that are on something where
you feel you can add a lot of value most
entrepreneurs don't do that to just
start up for you know a whim or
something to think they can make a lot
of money number two I would say is don't
try to do it without a customer so try
to build your custom try to build your
product around the customer it's a great
way to build a business because you have
feedback from somebody who's willing to
pay you to solve their problems soul of
entrepreneurs start a business because
the think a is a great idea and they
spend a lot of money and time and that's
spinning creating whatever product of
service and then it gets launched and
nobody buys it or five people by you
know you don't get enough money coming
in to keep the business open and you
look shutting down the better way to do
it is before you start launching your
business go and start talking to
potential customers ask them what the
problems are see if you can solve it for
them and try to get them to commit to
buying before you've actually created
whatever product or service you're going
to actually create so that's a great way
to do it you have customer buying you
have money coming in from day one it may
not be exactly what you had in mind from
the beginning but it's good because
you're building around real customer
problems and not just you know the idea
that you had in your head the third
thing is trying to do it all yourself
and this is a mistake a lot of
entrepreneurs make either because they
have trouble troubles delegating or to
think they could do it all themselves
you can't do it on yourself you have to
go and get help and recognize what
you're really good at where you add the
most value to your business so then I
ask myself all the time as I'm walked
into work is what can I do today that's
gonna add the most value to my business
it's not certain things that I'm really
good at sometimes it is but it's usually
the intersection of what I'm good at and
what I'm really passionate about and
uniquely now I'm able to deliver so what
is it that you're able to add the most
value to your business and then you know
eliminate automator or delegate out
everything else with your company and
that's a process it doesn't just happen
right away with every company but try to
figure out what's so unique about you
that will make your company different
and how can you spend a lot of your time
on that really important piece and not
everything else all the crap that comes
are going into business as well so don't
try to do it all yourself start on a
small scale the first person I hired was
one hour a day save me one hour day to
go and do other stuff with my business
things that I was really good at there's
a bunch of free programs you can get
with high school interns there's lots of
different ways it's not about the
resources you have but more how
resourceful you are so don't try to do
it yourself and that will help you build
your business so those are three common
pitfalls I hope that helps answer your
question good luck as you build your
business for those watching if you guys
liked the video please
a thumbs up below it always motivates me
to want to create more of these videos
and I'd love to hear what you have to
think you know if you agree with these
pitfalls or if you have others of your
own that you want to share please leave
it in the comments below and we'll see
you on the next episode
you